[Music]
anybody been seeing the latest craze
with this game called wordle oh yeah
world's fun man
can you explain the game so the game is
you have i believe five chances to guess
the word it's a five-letter word on your
phone you can do it on your phone you
can just go online on your app or that
app i'm sorry your uh browser is it like
jeopardy
not really no so basically you're trying
to guess what five letter word is the
word of the day the word word of the day
other hints no so what you do is on a
guess let's so let's say like um you you
uh for five letter word what's a good
father word let's say juice taste oh
taint juice let's say juice
let's okay juice for example because it
has um all different letters
so you'll have j-u-i-c-e oh if if one of
those letters is in the actual word
it'll be yellow it'll be marked yellow
that but that means that the that
letter's in the word but it's in the
wrong place but if it's green
so let's say u is green then that means
that's where u is in in the actual word
second place
so that will of fortune then kind of
yeah it's more like there's no velma
dude there's no velma yeah pointing to
the [ __ ]
that's fantastic
that don't sound right
yeah it's elvira i've been calling her
[ __ ] velma this whole time velma
valderrama with glasses and the
[Laughter]
um yeah so then like yeah the letter
turns green and this you have another
guess and this you're trying to
basically and people have different
strategies but you're trying to narrow
down um the the alphabet letters to get
like five letters they may not be in
order but you can you can unscramble
them and you want to get it before
obviously you have six tries you want to
get it before your six tries are up oh
what makes it social what makes it
social because you they make it very
easy for you to share your results
there's a share button and then they
even have a separate little like icon
that comes out when you share it with
your website how fast you got it right
yeah it shows you on which level like
the first doing the same word every day
yeah oh
okay you don't have a second try like if
you miss it you miss if you get it you
get it and there's only one word per day
and that's that's it and it's
international
midnight it's released at midnight did
you do yours for today
i didn't do mine yet today let's do it
right now on camera well actually you
know what i started it i may have
started in the morning
we got unlimited time just make sure you
know you have 24 hours oh i feel like i
started it and i'm not there yet this is
like the crossfit of word games because
crossfit you have a wad right which is
workout of the day and technically
everyone's supposed to run the same [ __ ]
but then gyms they they
see that technically there's like a
battle royale version of it you get to
kill people no it's like a it's like
there's a version of it online where
like you you're playing it against like
12 other people live and then you have
to do a bunch of them in a row and every
time you get one right you get more like
health and you take damage you damage
the other people oh that's cool
so you just like tetras yeah yeah yeah
remember it yeah it's like that dude do
people still play tetra i want to play i
haven't heard of that in a while this is
tetrance i remember we were talking
about tetrameter so i actually i
actually did it and i this is the first
time i missed so i had a street i had a
streak of 17. wow
and then i actually missed this one um i
thought the word was armor but it was uh
oh i don't want to say it oh actually it
won't matter i thought the word was
armor but it was actually amor
i think it was something that's a four
letter word
it was i thought it was armor but the
word was actually why aren't they
telling me
because the day's not over
yeah i thought it was armor it was
something else i forgot it's always a
five letter word it's always a five
letter word and then the hard ones are
when the letters repeat
oh because like you could have exhausted
much most of the alphabet enemy it was
enemy
enemies a six letter word
spike i'm kidding oh
no but yeah it was uh yeah so you have
to um guess at that point wow so let's
say you exhausted most of the alphabet
but they're repeating a letter
then it's like oh is it this and then
you know you got to kind of figure like
what it could be so this wordle craze is
obviously something that a lot of people
have been doing on social media stuff
like that and it turns out it was very
useful in one particular incident
because a chicago woman
was rescued
from a naked kidnapper thanks to wordle
naked kidnapped how the hell so he was
naked kidnapping her a naked man crept
into an 80 year old chicago woman's bed
and held her hostage for 17 hours what
the [ __ ] but she was finally rescued
after her daughter called the cost
because a woman hadn't texted her the
day's wordle
yeah answers a movie that's the next
minute that's crazy that's the next low
budget straight to streaming movies
defense though since she's 80 17 hours
is fast
yeah if they made a wordle movie based
on this and you thought it was going to
be all light-hearted and you go in
there's a rape scene yeah i know what
the [ __ ] this is not what you would
expect yeah that's the word gay video
christmas
you know it's like you think it's like a
[ __ ] family movie because it's about
a
word
true story based on true events i got
the word yeah
high five
can you go through the movie
don't spoil it for the next after you
[ __ ] naked as [ __ ] he's like
wow
got a hand switch naked as [ __ ] show us
how dangerous you are you know i have a
question how old was the kid does this
how old the kidnapper was uh the
kidnapper let's see oh yes yes 33 so so
and it's it's winter right now what is
it chicago he must be cold dude on drugs
for sure on drugs the lady was 80 years
old the intruder identified as 32 year
old james h davis iii oh i thought he
identifies as a 32 year old
his name is her husband god damn it yes
i i asked his age
i asked his age because i wonder if like
other women like in their 70s and 80s
are seeing this story and being like
i've got a shot with a 32.
yeah like i wish a 32 year old man would
crawl into my wedding
like like it's like you know hey playa
you don't need to kidnap me like just
ask
i'm here for you what's the [ __ ]
point
what was he i just picture a dude naked
as [ __ ] uh like crawling like a [ __ ]
gecko across the wall
his fingers are all wet
and then the ladies in the bed like what
the [ __ ]
he's all just like [ __ ] naked and
just crawling around the room so she was
actually her name is denise denise holt
she was asleep on saturday when the
mentally ill man broke into her home
uh and that's scary that's super scary
bloodied from the broken window as well
as he slipped into hulk's bed while
clutching a pair of scissors wow so that
fool jumped he just dove in butt ass
naked into the window covered in his own
blood yeah so the lady says uh in a
report she says i was in shock who tried
to remain calm during the ordeal i was
trying to survive that's all and he said
i won't harm you or molest you he
ordered her to take a shower with him
what that's molesting in her nightgown
what the [ __ ]
in her nightmare i won't molest you give
me a hand job
in her nightgown so he hasn't so he's
respectable he has a wet t-shirt fantasy
going maybe
i'm not gonna molest ya but you need a
shower with me right now this guy has a
coat i guess like what why he said no
i'm not warm enough we have to take a
bath
so they had to take it back after the
bath she said he dragged her around her
house
oh [ __ ] disconnected the phones and took
a couple of knives from the kitchen
before taking her to a bathroom in the
basement which he locked which he
blocked with a chair holy [ __ ] and to
pass the time she did exercises in total
darkness
oh wow he locked her in the basement
cool i didn't think i was going to live
i was doing marching and stretching as
much as i could
oh that's so sad doing marching and
stretching damn it's probably good for
her at her age though i know eventually
it keeps the daughter
caldwell who lives in seattle noticed
that her mother had not texted her about
the word logic puzzle as she usually
does whoa i didn't send my older
daughter a wordle in the morning and
that's what was disconcerting to her the
family then called police who reported
who responded to holt's home at about 9
40 p.m sunday and a swat team used a
stun gun to overpower the man after an
hours-long standoff
wow that's [ __ ]
i wonder what drugs he was on
like it's i've i've done dudes i've done
a lot of drugs bro like i've done a lot
of drugs right and you've only been like
naked crawling away
but
i haven't done heroin right and i
haven't done ayahuasca because those are
new [ __ ] right yeah so
i've never once
did anything like where i felt like i
needed to break into people's homes and
like you know keep them hostage or like
i never saw the devil you know i never
wanted to bite somebody because you know
[ __ ] john lennon told me to do it
like there's all these crazy ass things
maybe he's just looney tunes like the
guy that was crawling in the warehouse
yesterday
there was a guy crawling in the water so
like jayla's mom lives like next to this
like this whole commercial row of [ __ ]
and one of them set on fire
and uh this is a couple days ago just
yesterday
because i dropped because i dropped off
uh bart joe dropped me off and then
joe's like oh that place is on fire no
we hear someone yell at us and like what
was that and then we look up and there's
this crazy dude like crawling in the
warehouse that fool looks like jesus
yeah like i'm like i'm talking about the
when you go to uh uh church and then
there's a jesus like in those paintings
like he looks like a white dude with
long hair like a hipster right
yeah like jenkins that will have like a
stick like this and he was upstairs like
20 feet in the air uh because there's a
burnt down a whale
there's a burnt down warehouse we showed
the frames of the warehouse
so he's somehow upstairs and he's
[ __ ] waving around like he's [ __ ]
moses himself trying to like split the
red sea and [ __ ] right and he's like
saying hi and then bart's like he's
saying hi
i can't say hi to him because i said hi
to him last time
yeah because he's uh he hangs out there
so i used to see him all the time like
he would set up kitchen cabinets on the
sidewalk like he would set up a house or
whatever right and uh there's there's
like a problem in that neighborhood
obviously is when i come out
he would always try to say hi to me and
i don't want to encourage like the
behavior the behavior but he's like hi
neighbor and have more [ __ ] homies
pop out yeah but since i go to jio's mom
regularly like i just start to get more
desensitized to it so now when i see him
i'm like like that and i'm like oh [ __ ]
am i doing
i'm i'm establishing a connection now
he's a member of the community because
now he's gonna [ __ ] come and talk to
me and [ __ ] and i'm like oh god drinking
coffee hey neighbor good morning
how are you doing jk news again huh
yeah mom's house and he's like what's my
friend
he's a guest here next time we're like
how the [ __ ] did you end up here we
should interview that guy
jill's mom was like um she was like he
thinks he's porky pig
you